let's rewind to the 80s
meet ted
he owns a small beverage company that
sells smoothies and juices
ted purchased his first phone a bulky
handset that was in style at that time
his phone provided voice calls with the
help of first generation technology 1g
for his business back then 1g was more
than sufficient
in a decade's time ted's business
flourished due to the quality of his
products and services
ted wanted his customers to be loyal to
his brand and hence made customer
satisfaction a priority
for this ted decided to have a dedicated
customer support team to resolve any
customer issues faster so he and his
team upgraded to a better phone that not
only provided a higher speed but also
enabled services like text messaging and
multimedia messaging services
this was referred to as 2g
after two decades of selling smoothies
and juices ted had now become a leader
in this category
so he decided to diversify and expand
his business to other categories such as
soft drinks coffee yogurts croissants
macros etc
that meant he now had more products to
manufacture and more customers to serve
ted needed his business to keep up with
the competition and grow further without
compromising on quality
he was introduced to smartphones that
had a good data transmission speed
this technology was called 3g
with 3g in the market ted's business
benefited a lot more than before as he
was able to reach out to new customers
making them aware of his brand and new
products and solving any issues even
better
in the late 2000s with the internet
booming online business became a
necessity ted started selling beverages
coffee yogurts and a range of other
products online
at this point his company also started
brand advertising and he generated a lot
more business data than ever before he
became aware of the successor to 3g
4g
this next generation of wireless
technology boasted better multimedia
services higher speed and more security
ted was happy with his new 4g services
as he could sell marketers products
swiftly
but he thought 4g was sufficient for his
business and the maximum the domain of
wireless technology could ever evolve to
however with the enormous data that his
company generated and automation at its
peak ted had to store data in the cloud
and transform his manufacturing
processes
he was in need of more than just 4g to
stay connected in his business
with the huge number of investments in
his business and with the world turning
digital
ted wanted a faster and reliable network
connection for his firm that could use
his business data and sync the machine
tools and people to raise production and
deliver a better customer experience
he did his research and wondered how he
could achieve this and how to better
facilitate his business online
just then he came across the term 5g
ted learned that 5g could operate as
much as 10 times faster than 4g thereby
reaching a peak speed of 20 gigabytes
per second
he realized that 5g could really
transform his business by using robotics
and ai to pick and place raw and
processed foods
robots enabled with 5g could also help
him cut slice dispense sort and package
his products
and this is exactly what ted was looking
for
he was intrigued by the term 5g and went
on to understand what the hype was all
about and how different it was from its
predecessors
ted first learned that any information
that he sends or receives in a network
is carried through the air with the help
of radio frequencies
5g operates similarly however it uses
higher radio frequencies to carry more
information faster
the beauty of 5g that he discovered was
that 5g utilizes multiple input and
output antennas to avoid physical
objects like buildings and trees coming
in the way of communication further he
went on to understand that 5g consists
of two main components the radio access
network and the core network the radio
access network includes small cells
macro cells towers and home systems
connecting users like ted and devices to
the core network macro cells use
multiple input and output antennas that
enable one to send and receive large
volumes of data simultaneously
and small cells complement these macro
cells
meanwhile the core network of 5g manages
all the internet and data connections
the core network is designed to
integrate with the internet much more
efficiently
the core manages the advanced features
of 5g like network function
virtualization and network slicing
ted learned that network slicing is a
wise way of cutting the network into
several slices for a specific business
or industry for example emergency
services can work on a network slice
independently from virtual reality or a
business
all these nitty-gritty and benefits of
5g assured ted that 5g was exactly what
his firm needed at the moment to carry
out an interactive and hassle-free
business online
thus he incorporated 5g infrastructure
in his company business so here's a
question for you
which component of 5g manages network
function virtualization
a core network
b
radio access network
c radio access network and core network
d
none of the above
do give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
5g provides several applications and
opportunities across different sectors
5g will enable connecting more iot
devices and with less latency than 4g
with the advancement of 5g remote care
and remote surgery will be an incredible
site to witness
5g also can revolutionize public safety
the gaming market will also further
expand with the advancement in 5g
these were a few of the applications of
5g across sectors
5g deployment is preventing companies
from going out of business
going by the current reports samsung and
qualcomm have achieved yet another 5g
download speed milestone
now reaching 8.08 gigabytes per second
companies like apple and xiaomi are
readily rolling out 5g phones
according to statista in 2022 5g
subscriptions are expected to pass 1
billion
this shows how 5g will play a key role
in the years to come
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's a reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon for more on the latest
technologies and trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simplylearn
[Music]
you